artificial intelligence has been
threatening everyone's jobs including
interpreters
inaccurate interpretation can be the
difference between a good or bad nuclear
deal so why are tested a speech
translator called Kudo versus human
interpreters to see which better
transmits all of the necessary elements
for people to understand what they are
hearing including emotion intonation
completeness spontaneity and speed
Liar's jobs to test out if AI is really
better than a human let's begin
test one
here we go we gave Barry and Kudo a 2020
speech from King Felipe of Spain the
speech is about the covid crisis the
subjects will focus on emotion it's
because of the pandemic I parachuted
into this not knowing anything about the
speech when it was given in this speech
what matters more is the emotion and the
ability to connect with the audience
because he's speaking to the citizens of
Spain at a very difficult time when many
have suffered loss are going through a
number of challenges this reminds us of
very deep feelings
at this time many of you are fighting
against the illness and
what it has done in your homes and the
words are just the vehicle to get that
across now let's evaluate the speech
translator
good evening I address you on this
Christmas Eve
when we are living truly exceptional
circumstances due to the pandemic
in terms of content and completeness the
AI did very well the virus has broken
into our lives
bringing suffering sadness or fear
altered our way of life it struggled
with word choice in a number of areas it
referred to an overflow in some
hospitals and also overflow in some of
our Hospitals now what that was
referring to is at that time when
hospitals were overwhelmed when the King
was recognizing the health care workers
for the work that they had done and he
recognized the tremendous physical and
emotional burden that they were carrying
and the AI translated that as the great
emotional charge and physics on their
backs if you know Spanish you can go
back and figure out how it is that the
AI determined to use those words but
obviously that is
borderline nonsensical if you look at
what the speech to speech translation
produced it was by and large
quite accurate however
it's very difficult to get the sense of
what the king is seeking to portray
through the AI in its current state test
two spontaneity we gave Walter and Kudo
a 2021 speech from former Senator and
now current Colombian president Gustavo
Petro the most powerful and
non-productive sectors of this country
20 billion pesos a year so I took the
hour beforehand to look him up look at
some of his videos just listen to the
level of language he employs listen to
his rhythms listen to you know watch his
body language now let's see how the
speech translator did you are Mr
President in office
assist you
in the year of 2019 this Congress
decided to give to the most powerful and
unproductive sectors of the country 20
billion pesos a year the particular
strength of artificial intelligence was
in capturing those terms of art
artificial intelligence captured
president in office or sitting president
Minister of Finance ministro de Hacienda
special drawing rights that's a
consecrated term it's a term that's
enshrined that you can find in any
number of glossaries that's the official
translation and I I miss that official
caucuses as well that the artificial
translation rendered that very clearly
and it pulls those in and did so very
well that's what I felt it was most
effective at and where I felt it had the
most shortcomings was because of the
pauses when Al Pace has a stagnant
economy and an impoverished middle class
what this tax form brings
it is to increase taxes on the
productive company small and medium
fundamentally
absolute contradiction and absurdity the
artificial intelligence creates these
little Islands these little bubbles that
read like complete thoughts but are not
because there's a flow
there's a flow that's coming after the
pause and thanks
to an absolutely aggressive social
policy
making a gift to the bankers and thanks
to an absolutely aggressive social
policy how to issue money to give to
Bankers so the pause is in this
particular speech seem to throw the
artificial intelligence off you have the
vocal inflection increasing taxes on
those who govern Colombia that you know
allows you to understand there's
something else coming I'm not finished
yet unproductive Capital those who don't
work
but
prey on the state on the people and on
nature
thank you sir task 3 we give Barry and
Kudo a 2021 speech from El Salvadorian
president naibukele the speech is highly
crafted prepared and read from a
teleprompter at a high rate of speed we
are going to make use of bandisal I will
tell you that it was a very challenging
experience for me as a professional
interpreter to interpret that speech
accurately and completely what you have
to do is process that information and
extract the ideas to be able to give
your listener something that's usable
for them to be able to follow from that
huge amount or that torrent of words
that's coming at you now let's evaluate
the speech translator
Salvadoran people good morning as you
all know
the world has suffered an increase in
prices when I was able to go back and
listen to the AI interpretation what I
noticed throughout the entire speech is
that it did not miss any of the content
of these Goods increases to match the
supply of new dollars new Euros
therefore that affects World prices
is why we are experiencing a global
inflation that hits the pockets of
everything of all the people in the
world and El Salvador is no exception I
was
taken aback by the artificial
intelligence's ability
to get all of the content and hold on to
it so in terms of completeness it was
very good and better than what I was
able to do at that rate of speed however
it often had mistakes and and challenges
with making the syntax the word choice
and sometimes the grammar in English and
sometimes it would choose words that
weren't really
the most accurate way the way a native
English speaker would say something it
talked about new currency issues this
inflation generated by the incorporation
of new currency issues usually dollars
Euros Yen which was really ambiguous
because it was talking about new
infusions of cash or currency into the
monetary system and people could confuse
issues with problems and think okay
what's the problem with these new
currencies what is happening is that the
process that the professional
interpreter has been doing for as long
as professional interpreters have been
working is to process that information
and then serve it up to the listener
already processed to know this is what's
being talked about so rather than saying
new currency issues I would have said
infusions or injections of more cash
into the monetary system so for a
profession that started with the
Nuremberg trials and continues to be
used for important meetings and
negotiations today okay
when is it appropriate to use an AI
solution I would say an informal
situations
situations where there is not a high
level of consequence for mistakes I
would not trust this
in courtrooms I would not trust this in
the legal system if there is a decision
that has to be made a medical
interaction Asylum cases I don't know
that I would trust it for situations
that require metaphorical language that
don't catch the figurative meaning do I
want to have a high level Diplomat or a
president of my country speaking to
another president through AI to make
important decisions about the future of
literally millions of lives no we need
to look at it we need to examine it we
need to find out how we can use this
constructively and how we can use it
carefully to Aid us and not be afraid of
it because that's no use if we're not
flexible we're eminently in a world
where we need to be flexible and we need
to be open to new ideas and new ways of
doing things it is not a replacement and
you have to understand that and if we're
able to understand the power of the tool
we can respect the tool and use it to
everyone's benefit